[Music]
thank you
we're out of syrup there's clearly some
syrup at the bottom of that bottle might
take some elbow grease but I have faith
you'll get at least a stack of pancakes
worth out of there more importantly
though the bottle's just sitting at the
table without a cap on and there's no
cap we can see on the table where did
that calf go is the syrup even good
anymore now that it's been exposed to
the elements is there air you don't know
maybe I'll use my intern gluty gluty
arrives from off screen as if he
appeared out of a [ __ ] portal syrup
in hand but how did he know that Rick
was even in need of syrup I mean maybe
Rick staged this so he could introduce
his intern but how did he know the syrup
wasn't going to run out before it got to
him and why does he even care about
introducing the intern other than to set
up an underwhelming B
plus also the syrup bottle glooty is
using doesn't have a [ __ ] lid on it
either what does his family do with the
lids are they monsters no if you'll
excuse me wait he just dragged his board
and turn into syrup his pancakes and now
he's just going to [ __ ] off feels like
Rick went to the every CEO ever School
of treating interns when grandparent
pets his belly like that and leaves
without Morty means he's going to go
poop I guess it's that time of day a
when we sin that Rick isn't using his
portal gun he doesn't have a problem
using it later in the episode and I
don't know about you but when I realize
it's time to drop the kids off at the
pool the last thing I want between me
and the community center is a car ride
honey why can't you get this excited
about your SATs asking this instead of
wondering why summer knows so many
specifics about her grandfather's
Hershey squirts well I'm man enough to
Simply say I'm going to poop defining
your masculinity by a willingness to
announce your Readiness to sit the
porcelain Throne when you're barely
competent enough to be defined as
sentient assuming that Rick sinks the
Bismarck once a day like a regular human
that is regular right wouldn't this path
be well trodden I suppose this could be
a magically regrowing field slash Meadow
slash macroscopic cilia Farm but I
refuse to keep filling in the narrative
gaps in the show until I get an official
writing credit reverse digestion
extrapolation here's a sin for the
several minutes a Heisman trying to
imagine slash sketch the anus that would
make the geometry of this pre-owned
nutrient log possible time to meet your
maker nice try but time to meet your
eater would be far more accurate I can't
see how there's any way of knowing ahead
of time that the maker was the eater
also how is the turd pewter only picking
up on the sandwich shouldn't be a
selection of well other two what are you
guys doing did you develop an app but if
gluty already had the app design handy
what exactly did he need Jerry for if
this is his species way of stealing
water from the planet why not just
develop the app immediately what's the
point of all this do you want to develop
an app pomping circumstance rule number
one in app development son never follow
the rules that's when the
an alien's forehead dad why why do you
think Rick would have that rule Morty
would be excellent at TV sins but the
sin here is that Rick should have known
this was a likely possibility and should
have either a found a serp delivering
intern without a don't develop my deadly
app caveat or B not left said intern
with the primordial smegma film that
Evolution deemed necessary to give the
most basic self-awareness to called
Jerry guys we're getting our first users
and it just happens to be summer because
coincidence thy name is Rick and Morty
this new app just matched me with a guy
that is Sue My Thai
super my type learn to agree Beth wasn't
[ __ ] asking you what you meant summer
so there was no need to explain and how
was the explanation 10 times more
irritating to hear than the thing you
said false okay your Sue Tai works at
Jersey Mike's and sees 25 fish shows a
year then Danny must be independently
wealthy because tickets along with all
the drugs you would have to purchase for
25 fish shows aren't cheap this world
cares too much about bands and too
little about love and I Think I Love You
Tommy as the beeping Tommy has the
Peeping Tommy Tommy Tommy Tommy Tommy
just sitting the fact that any menu
claiming to have the best frog food
would advertise this basic ass sandwich
and not its fleice cream cheeseburger or
Aunt Jovi Pizza
he knows where I live He's Crazy you
have 470
000 messages we're just left to imagine
how Rick was able to find and leave
voicemails with 470
000 flies and just accept that it
happened even if he managed to automate
some of the voicemails how is this his
best option if he's not afraid of
murdering child flies why is the far
more convenient decision to torture this
adult fly not top of the list
[Music]
you 800
000 kids thinking the amount of children
one has coincides with how many they're
willing to let die I mean it totally
does but we're not supposed to announce
that to the world I'm not arguing that
being hit by a car isn't an effective
form of contraception but it sure does
feel like dealing with the Splinter and
a finger by removing the entire arm had
you bothered Thomas to love you would
have learned by now it is as abundant as
water you know what isn't water so we'll
be taking yours oxymoronic expositioning
aside Xbox
we've got an aliens come to Earth to
steal our resources cliche boy scoping
for this [ __ ] then crack knees my
wife's still alive she's she went into
remission 10 years ago what did you do
today oh I uh booped on a really awesome
toilet I found wait a [ __ ] minute
let's talk about the villain's plan here
Rick just found and traveled to an
alternate universe to find a Tony who
used his toilet despite his wife still
being alive and then dragged him in
front of this universe of Stoney to
prove he's lying putting aside the fact
that he found the perfect Tony in a
matter of seconds what the [ __ ] does
that even prove unless Rick can say that
every Tony in every Universe makes this
Choice regardless of circumstances this
doesn't prove [ __ ] so next time you
stumble onto a toilet that feels too
good for your ass trust me it is but how
did Tony even find the damn thing in the
first place and why didn't Rick have any
sort of defense or Shield or [ __ ]
laser beam that turns you inside out and
teleports you into the final days of a
civilization that Prides itself on
flaying any and all visitors with a lime
soaked cheese grater before they fall
into the abyss of a black hole I think
he'd get a kick out of that
I suppose we can add allowing your anus
to give the finger to an alien to the
list of defecated fours after you left I
thought about what you said and how much
I needed it skip you
pooping too this
now you're supposed to poop either that
or God knows something about pooping we
don't regardless I'm torn grossed out
and very confused come poop with me poop
with me Tony aren't you gonna join us in
the pooping Tony how's the pooping Donny
how's the pooping
tiny tiny you can make a perfectly
realized toilet-filled simulation of
heaven but you can't share a toilet Tony
would be the king of his own Throne at
TV sins I get that this drawing is
likely gibberish chiefly because Jerry
drew it but at some point I have to
wonder how even his lonely brain cell
doesn't realize the futility of its
actions like why spend the time drawing
a portal gun you don't possess a grandpa
that isn't here or a baseball bat you
don't have come on adventures of Jerry
and Morty okay
premature Jerry is a burden to the
oxygeny breeze and didn't even deserve
this pity five vibration
but I'm assuming you chose this [ __ ]
thing as your method of locomotion so
what the [ __ ] were you expecting here
where's your daughter hey you're right
she join Isis we've got Isis jokes y'all
that's what I thought gluty looks like
you and I
are all we got well this worked out
conveniently enough for Jerry that I'm
awarding it 10 sins then those 10 cents
will be awarded their tencent matches
which they will then cheat on each other
with the other 10 sins you know what
just add the damn sins already
[ __ ] that's my name don't wear
it out is it though I mean it's not
beyond the realm of what the show is
capable of but that feels more like a
season six style of episode considering
the presence of Sam Neal Jeffrey Wright
and Taiko itd I'm genuinely shocked that
this scene does not contain a Ted Danson
also look I'm not one for promoting
infidelity but if Ted Danson wants you
to cheat on your husband then you cheat
on your husband that is Ted dancing
people this episode is 37 defecation and
honestly I'm pooped out enjoy using it
all by yourself while you sit there and
think about how nobody wants to be
around you however only Rick and Morty
could turn the active decorating
porcelain into a beautiful metaphor
about how a hoarding precious things is
not as fulfilling as we believe in the
true Joys and the sharing of said things
with the people you love and for
bringing that home by making Rick suffer
through his own booby trap I shall
happily allow the sin counter to drop a
deuce
foreign
ER in here rule number one in app
development son never follow the rule
what you've just said is one of the most
insanely idiotic things I have ever
heard I created the events Horizon to
reach the Stars she's gone much much
farther than that tell them what you
told me this can't be happy you can't be
here it doesn't make sense for you to be
here
ounces are a thousand eight balls do on
a grounds 80. it's all pre-buy and I
tell you like I tell all my boys if you
caught it any more than it already is
you can say goodbye to repeat cost
time to be free what the sh Adventures
of Jerry and Morty huh put her there at
no point in your rambling incoherent
response were you even close to anything
that could be considered a rational
thought I started today disgusted and
embarrassed to be your son and then
later I thought we were gonna die
because you're a loser
no notes